ان الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اذ
قال رئيس دونيتك الموالي لروسيا دانس
بوشنا ان القوات الاوكرانيه تنقل جنود من
خيرس الى دونيتك معظمهم من جنود الاحتياط
اما الجيش الاوكراني فقال انه يجري تجهيز
قطارات لاجلاء المدنيين من سكان خرسون الى
مقاطعه خملينسكي غربيه البلاد وذلك بسبب
اشتداد القصف الروسي كما قال الجيش
الاوكرانيين قصف الروسيا استهدف البنيه
التحتيه في مقاطعه جنيبر جنوبيه الميلاد
واضافت ان روسيا قصفت احدى مضخات المياه
التي تمر من غير
سندها قالت سلطاتهم ربع مليون شخص في
المقاطعه دون ماء او كهرباء
قالت السلطات المواليه لروسيا ان اكثر من
700 جنديا من القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه
يتمركزون في محيط سفاروجيا ويتم اعدادهم
الاقتحام المحطه النوويه في المقطعه
اما المتحدث باسم الكرملاند متر بيسكوف
فنفى ما يروج من معلومات عن انسحاب روسيا
من المحطه التبرجيا وقال امسكه في انه
ليست هناك حاجه للبحث عن مؤشرات غير
موجوده بخصوص امكانيه الانسحاب من المحطه
وينضم العنين من نيكولا مراسلنا تامر
الصمادي اذا تامر حدثنا عن الوضع من اكثر
من زاويه طبعا الميداني الانساني
ايضا اخر التطورات السياسيه تفضل
نعم ليله نتواجد على اطراف ميكو لايف
واطراف غير سون ايضا هنالك تشابك وقرب
استراتيجي جغرافي بين المدينه
اللتين تتعرضا لقصف مستمر من قبل القوات
الروسيه على مدار الساعه خلال ساعات
الصباح اعلنت السلطات المحليه في ميكو
لايف عن تدمير احد همم محطات او محطات
بالفعل احدى محطات المياه التي تضخ المياه
الى ميكو لايف عن طريق خيرسون القصب في
يتواصل على منطقه اشتوكه ايضا في ميكو
لايف والعديد من الكره والبلدات
على خطوط التماس بين ميكولاي فاخر تطورات
ايضا في خرسان المتسارعه خلال ساعات همم
الرئيس الاوكراني بالفعل بان القصف يشتد
على عموم اقليم خير تحدث عن اكثر من 200
و40 قصه في تعرضت له المدينه على مدار هذا
همم على مدار الاسبوع الماضي وهذه الايام
خلال الساعات الاخيره ايضا تحدثت القياده
العسكريه في خرسان عن اكثر من 40 قصف
مدفعي تعرضت له مناطق متفرقه من المدينه
لكن على الجهه المقابله من طرفي نهر دنيبر
الذي يفصل خرسون الى جزئين هنالك اشتباكات
وقصف وقصف متبادل بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والروسيه بالمدفعيه تقول القوات
الاوكرانيه انها تكذب من قصفها على مناطق
تواجد وتمركز القوات الروسيه في الضفه
اليمنى منها دنيبر وتؤكد ايضا ما اشار
اليه الطرف الروسي او القوات المواليه
لروسيا خلال الساعات الاخيره من انها ترصد
وكانت ترصد على مدار ثلاثه ايام الماضيه
انسحاب لعدد من القوات
الروسيه المتواجده على ظهر على ضفه نهر
دنيبر باتجاه مناطق دنيا دنيا تقول بانها
تضرب تضرب عفوا الخطوط الامداد
المتواصله والتي تصل بين ضفتنا دينيبر على
وشبه جزيره القرم للقوات الروسيه وتقول
بان القوات الروسيه لن تصمت طويلا تتحدث
خلال اليومين الماضين كانت تتحدث السلطات
الاوكرانيه عن ربما ثلاثه اسابيع قد تصمت
فيها القوات الروسيه قبل ان تنسحب من عموم
خرسون او من الضفه الاخرى على نهر دنيبر
كما تقول ايضا التطورات في الحقيقه ليلى
متزارعه ومتسارعه جدا في زبرجه يوم امس
قال قالت الرئاسه مؤسسه الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه بانها همم بان القوات
الاوكرانيه سوف تتسلم بالفعل محطه زبرج
لانهويه قريبا وقالت همم بان القوات
الاوكرانيه تتقدم شيئا فشيئا باتجاه
المحطه محطه الطاقه النوويه هناك وقالت
ايضا القوات الاوكرانيه تحديدا قياده
عمليات الجنوب بان
دفاعات خاصه بالقوات الروسيه بدات تتقهكر
وهذه الدفاعات قريبه كثيرا من المحطه
والتطورات بالتاكيد في ميليتوبيل تقول
القوات الاوكرانيه هناك في زبروجه بانها
تكثف من قصفها لمواقع توركز القوات
الروسيه هناك ونهايه فيني كوبل حيث دين
برو القصف متواصل وفقا للسرطان هناك
والحديث عن اكثر من 70 حديثه قصفت فيها
المدينه فجر هذا اليوم نعم اشكرك جزيلا
تامر على كل هذه المعلومات من ريفه شكرا
لك